come on Harry what are you waiting for
we know how hard you're crushing on Ouma
and it looks like she's crushing on
YouTube but she's not gonna wait around
forever she's got big plans when she
gets off the Isle of the Lost
if you're going to make your move you
better do it quickly because see witches
aren't known for staying flipped for too
long they're gonna forget that girl and
remember the name ever since descendants
to fans have been totally shipping Ouma
and Harry it's clear from their
chemistry that these two scallywags have
deep feelings for each other we've got
some major science about their romantic
destiny watch until the end to find out
how these two will end up together in
descendents three Harry and Ouma or Huma
has fans love to call them have an
undeniable connection these two are
absolutely destined to be together if
you look at their history you'll see it
they both have evil parents who come
from the sea we know that umas mom is
Ursula the sea witch and of course
Harry's dad is the famous Captain Hook
it's like they practically have steam
water pumping through their veins they
get each other like no one else
villain kids already have a common
understanding of what it's like to grow
up on the Isle but in Harry and umas
case they have the sea life elements as
well and from the way they look at each
other it's obvious that they have a
heart-to-heart connection that goes way
above and beyond captain and first mate
the chemistry between uma and Harry goes
way back all the way back to the books
and rise of the Isle of the Lost
they are totally pining for each other
there's one scene in the book in which
Emma reminded Harry that he works for
her she firmly told him that she's the
captain and he's the first mate Harry
replied with a wink implying that she
really meant to say first date Harry's
response says it all
he was strutting around and showing off
for uma which made her laugh she told
him to shut up and see to the sail on
the ship and the pages of the book
almost caught fire from the hot
attraction between these two back toward
to the movies in descendants to the
sparks are really flying because uma and
Harry during their song what's my name
they share a lot of flirty moments one
particularly big moments is when uma
slides her sword through Harry's hook
and the flirting doesn't stop there she
touches his arm when she is seen about
wanting to see all eyes on her and
there's a part where you McGrath Harry's
hook and says hook me then she smiled at
him as if to say she is so into him
Harry laughs an Ummah playfully bumps
him but even if they never touched all
you have to do is watch their eyes luma
winks at Harry again during his rap
performance we think we know whose eyes
she really wants on her and speaking of
eyes did you see how he was looking at
her before the song even starts
uma asks Harry what her name is Harry
gets down on one knee takes off his
pirate hat and slowly says uma he has so
much admiration in his eyes it's
surprising she didn't jump into his arms
right then and there and he was on one
knee as if he was proposing to her in
that very moment in fact throughout the
whole song every time Harry gazes at uma
he's practically got hearts for eyes
seriously he cannot stop staring at her
and following her everywhere she seems
like you've lost your time there's
another cute scene between Harry and uma
in descendants - in this scene uma
brings Harry a plate of food but then
she reaches over to take a piece of food
off the tray if you know anything about
pirates you know that Sharon isn't
exactly a behavior they are known for if
anybody else had tried to take food off
of Harry's plate they would have found a
hook in their hand but he lets zoom and
do whatever she wants afterwards she
throws food at the TV screen which was
featuring her arch-nemesis math and
Harry immediately starts laughing it's
as if he enjoys her every move even if
she is wasting his food he even grabs
more of his own food and throws it at
the TV screen in solidarity with uma and
there are a couple of moments when it
looks like they might kiss in this scene
when
uma is talking about how much she
despises mouth she gets close to Harry
they are locked in a passionate stare it
looks like they want to kiss each other
so bad and of course there's a moment in
nuuma song when Harry gazes up at her as
she runs her fingers through his hair
you guys the screen is melting it's
clear that Harry just wants to be by his
side as they take over the aisle the sea
and our Don together Harry really
believes in uma he sticks with her no
matter what to the very end
so how will their romance play out in
descendents 3 we caught a revealing
glimpse of uma Harry and Gill together
in the latest official trailer Harry is
looking really excited about whatever
the future holds
uma turn
aheri as she says this is a job for
pirates later we see the look on Harry's
face he is ecstatic Harry will do
literally anything Huma wants if emma
does become the queen of the sea that
would make Harry the king now we can see
why he is so thrilled to be by uma side
again but will there be another steamy
villian song featuring uma and Harry
tell us what you think and leave an
octopus emoji in the comments if you're
shipping uma and Harry as much as we are
don't forget to subscribe and stay to
speed with our latest d3 theories and
give this video a big thumbs up if you
want to see Harry and uma together in
the upcoming movie thanks for watching
the things catch you next time
[Music]